[Music]
you know suits aren't just for suits
anymore finding that perfect fit isn't
just about finding the right cut of
fabric it's about finding the right kind
of fabric for the right cut of man
you're going to like the way you look
i guarantee it
sorry cut we have to cut
what's this
are you kidding me
the right cut of fabric for the right
cut of man
you're gonna like the way you look and
due to a pending lawsuit i'm legally
unable to guarantee it
sorry is it just me that does not sound
right for the right cut of man
you're gonna like the way you look
and while i don't guarantee it let's
just say i strongly feel that there's a
very good chance that you
in one of our suits will most likely
like the way that you look okay you know
what no cut you're gonna like the way
you look
these opinions stated make no assurances
that one person or persons may or may
not like enjoy or harbor positive
feelings towards one's physical
appearance heretofore known as the way
you look
no guarantees are being made throughout
the known universe says
this is [ __ ] what this is [ __ ]
we have to do it one guy sues because he
doesn't like the way he looks and now i
gotta read this legally nonsense
there's a chance you're gonna like the
way you look and there's a chance that
you won't it could be 50 50 but i like
to think it's more like 80 20. okay are
you kidding me
let's just say i guarantee one of the
following three phrases
i am a woman
i am a black woman
you're gonna like the way you look
quantum physics says anytime a choice is
made two realities are spawned
what i'm saying is i think once you put
on one of our suits there's a very good
chance you're going to find yourself in
the universe the parallel universe where
you in fact do enjoy the way that you
look come on cut
this noise i've been making this
guarantee for 20 years
20 years fine i i won't say i guarantee
it okay all right fine all right ready
and action you're gonna like the way you
look
they got on diesel okay no spanish
fabuloso
i guarantee it come on i said guarantee
it's a word i made up okay what does it
mean then
it means i guarantee it let's just say
that this gesture
means i guarantee whatever i just said
okay come on no you're gonna like the
way you look cut i've seen a lot of men
put on a lot of suits and i guarantee it
i'm gonna kick your ass phil can i
guarantee that you're gonna like the way
you look
and while i cannot guarantee that you
will like the way you look there's
nothing in the cease and desist that
says a minor who has no relationship to
me cannot guarantee it
piper
you're going to like the way you look
he guarantees it no you can't you know
what
if you don't like the way you look you
come to 9211 ocean view drive that's my
home address and i will knife fight you
all right i will not i [ __ ] guarantee
it the sun is going to rise in the east
and set in the west pizza will always
taste better the next day and you're
going to
love
not like
love the way you look in your goddamn
suit i will class you up and get you
laid you pig
put on the
suit and love the way you look it's silk
from italy i got it in italy
you know who liked the way they looked
phil
your wife when we made love in your
attic wait what she liked the girth of
my unit
i guarantee it
i'm out
god this suit looks like [ __ ]
[Music]